e
uh certainly the things that we did with
463 uh we're in attempt to uh re a a a
good compromise we received lots and
lots of letters about people believing
that this would allow the process that
somebody could go in apply for an
absentee ballot or whatever register to
vote and never see an election official
certainly we tried to make that clear
with the words present down in the
bottom and adding the requirements in
all of the different forms the
registration form not in this doc
docment with the absentee form in this
document and the portal uh that people
put down the last four digit social
security number driver's license or non
driver ID or a checker box that says
they don't have either uh we think it's
a reasonable compromise
the I know that there has been push back
on the portal portion of this uh
certainly uh part of what we're trying
to do there is so that people um who are
going to register uh could go to the
portal get uh you know send an email to
the people get the forms back from them
and you know bring them right to the
election on Election Day cutting down
the lines that would be there um the
other important parts is the reason that
the uh absentee request form was changed
is due to the there really is no ID
requirements you know for absentee
balance uh so having those um extra
fields in there gives us a better um you
know check on uh who's applying uh and
then certainly the funding that is in
there uh part for the portal uh but also
part for verification of Voters and the
way that's expanding uh in some of the
conversations that I've had on
1370 um that is important in fact in the
latest revision of uh
1370 um I put instead of a dollar I put
$100,000 in there um to fund the group
that would do the
verification um that would either need
to be in here or in 1370 if we're going
to do that so I don't know if any of the
issue seeing none I guess back to you
allocations I had the impression that
the $50,000 was also in another bill Am
I Wrong uh it was originally in a Senate
bill but you guys have put that on hold
I believe uh and that's why it was added
here is to make it easier uh to go
through I don't exactly know what you
guys status on that uh Senate bill is uh
but it only needs to be provided once
for that function but now that we're
expanding that group that would do the
verifications uh that is why like I said
in 1370 I asked for 100,000 or if we do
something different here with the portal
uh I would want to retain some of that
money if I don't put it in 1370 so again
it's funded in one place and you're good
okay and it it's not already in
1370 1370 The Way It Was Written so that
it didn't have to go to finance was that
it was written with appropriation of $1
and then I put the appropriation in
463 uh which was already going to go to
finance
okay got it
discussion um I have a question about
the absentee ballot requirements why why
are we adding absentee ballot
requirements into a portal Bill uh one
of the functions of the portal uh was
the ability to request an absentee
ballot uh so if we were when I I changed
the portal bill so that I had
identification I know that senator Susi
on the senate floor um questioned you
know why we were asking for more
identification and I said well Senator
Susi it would be a travesty if someone
went in and used your identity and
changed you from a Democrat to a
Republican and you weren't able to run
for office uh so again to make all the
forms consistent if you look at the
other all of the the registration form
the request for absentee ballot and in
this
also the portal uh would all be
requesting that four digits of the
social security number to help prove
identity and uh make sure that we're not
requests follow
up um at least as I read it this is
asking for more identification than is
currently required to request an
absentee ballot correct and and it goes
beyond what is in the current statute
for identification correct is is there a
reason for that uh there are people who
think that our current practice um does
not identify uh people uh that
especially abente ballots uh are
vulnerable to
people um and so in an effort to uh make
it easy to vote but hard to cheat uh we
tried to add some information that's
very easy for people to obtain um you
know you your parents now when you uh
they want to file the taxes get you a
social security number when you're just
a baby um and so you live with that
so people know their social security
numbers and then if you have a license
or a non driver ID uh that again is easy
information where you were born you know
that kind of thing again it's all easy
information that a person uh who is a
legitimate voter can you know copy down
very quickly uh and complete that and
those uh data elements will be in the
database and able to be verified against
what the voter put
in represent
qu uh thank you Mr chairman uh Senator I
also have a question about the absentee
ballot application
form it appears to me when it comes to
what I'll call the winter weather
exception that the version of the form
in in this bill perpetuates an
inconsistency in the current statutes in
that it reads for use only on the Monday
immediately prior to the election
National Weather Service has in issued a
winter storm
warning uh and then in the two
paragraphs below where it says I am
elderly or infirm and then I anticipate
that school Child Care adult care will
be cancelled that that
area uh when we uh excuse me a moment
when we look at eligibility under 657
colon one in the current
statutes the uh I'm again going to call
the winter storm exception it just
uh that a person uh has concerns for his
or her
safety and a person who cares for
children and firm adults it it does not
have a requirement that you state you're
elderly or infirm or have a physical
disability so I see that as an
inconsistency in the form compared to
the eligibility portion of the statute
6571 uh Roman numeral 2 if you're
looking at page three of the bill the
information that was changed is
highlighted there in bold letters uh the
rest is the statute as it was written um
and there is or was a u a bill that came
to us that requested some changes to
that um I'm not sure that the status of
that and if we did change it then this
will will change to go along with it uh
I believe that bill was HB 1119 if I
remember correctly and I uh it's my
recollection correct me if I'm wrong but
I believe that went to interim study
then okay thank thank you representative
Lane so confirm the existing statute is
what's reflected in here best I know and
uh except for the changes involed it's
uh yes this is reflecting the existing
statute when it comes the definition of
the absentee ballot application but that
itself is currently in consistent with
the eligibility requirements and I'm I'm
suggesting basically this would be an
opportunity to bring the application and
the eligibility portion of the statute
uh into
consistency um again since the Senate
has already taken a position on that
other bill um I don't know that uh we
would have to caucus to see if we could
support that or not but uh right now um
what's in front of us is is the changes
that you see okay thank you for your
answer but chair if I might add to that
um we did the Senate did have a position
of passing um s SP 535 which did correct
this statutory inconsistency as well so
um I believe it would be something
consistent with Senate previous Senate
action what was the final status of that
one I believe we sent it over to the
house who tabled it because there was HB
1119 which we then sent to interim
study so there you
go uh certainly you know we would be
but so I think that the most likely
outcome here is probably no report on
463 having said that the $50,000
allocation for determining the
qualification of
Voters is there another bill before us
today where we could reasonably include
that considering we're supposed to work
with what's
there um those that appropriation could
be put into uh 1370 in my opinion um
that already had the appropriation of
the
$1 uh and the number the place keeper i'
put in in that Amendment uh was only a
place keeper just to so uh that those
fund
to uh if we're going to really do 1370
and have a group that will help the
voters uh provide their documentation
Etc um and also that money can be used
for uh if a a person comes in and they
move from Manchester Ward one to
Manchester Ward 7 uh right now at the
polling place uh they can't look up the
people and know that they were
previously registered so that is one of
the objections is that they would have
to prove citizenship and uh an age uh
but one of the things that uh the
secretary of state is uh uh at least to
me seems agreeable to is providing a
tablet that would have the
database uh on it so that when a voter
comes in and says I was registered in
Manchester 1 and now we're in seven they
would be able to look them up and real
time right there at the pole I shouldn't
say real time they will be able to look
them up uh at the polls because these
would not be connected to the internet
it would have the database stagnant on
there uh and then they would only have
to prove identity and doile which is the
current
statute and if I can ask you a
legislating for dummy's question is it
as simple as 1370 changing the $1 to 50
grand um again if we're going to do the
added things uh I wouldn't the 50 Grand
probably would not be sufficient
especially if I'm going to buy the
tablets so that's why I moved it from to
up to
100,000 um also the revision that I put
in in
1370 uh would have an extended period
for the data verification uh so that
group maybe stood up for a longer period
of time uh than it was originally
anticipated and that also would have an
added
expense all right anything
further and I think we're going to close
463 and we're a few minutes behind our
on what's up
okay well pass him out anyway pass them
out
anyway
am
e
all right we're going to open the
1091 and representative Lane can you
explain your
proposal uh yes the proposal
incorporates uh the changes that I sent
around when we were discussing yesterday
at Senate Bill
534 um so it incorporates those it also
incorp Ates a few changes that Senator
Susi wanted to make so we did that and
then we incorporated um the change about
the mandatory electronic
filing um so that it starts in uh for
the election of
2026 for the governor and executive
counsel um and then in for the election
of 2028 it's mandatory for everybody
else and uh it's optional um of course
for any anybody who wishes to file up
but it only becomes mandatory for
2028 and that's pretty much
2247 arrived on my desk it it just it
just arrived on my desk five minutes ago
too and unfortunately I did not keep a
draft of the changes but um the first
change that I see is down on page um one
on line um 18 uh it's received
contributions it looks like make is um
highlighted I thought that was in the
original draft but um there was uh
Senator Susie wanted to remove the word
political
party was it from what was
me it was um in Roman it's on uh page
one Roman numeral 3 line
20 21 the word um political party was in
there and she asked that it be removed
so that was
[Music]
on page
two if you don't mind just repeating the
last
one page number one line
21 the words political party were
removed so it said for the success or
defeat of a political party candidate
blah and she said we agreed that it was
superflous and it didn't really need to
the term candidate candidates measure
measures is repeated throughout the bill
the chapter throughout the
bill um on line two page 22 the word uh
for the definition of
contribution um it's for Value received
or made the re she again Senator Susie
asked that received be put in there um
rather than the other way around made be
put in rather than received and when we
talked about it we decided it really
need to be both because it would catch
both the donor and the uh political
committee to which it was
paper if you go over
expenditure um I don't know what line
that's on we wish that we could have
um
right right going to the bottom of page
um it's independent expenditure actually
go to the bottom of page three the
language that was changed is as it is
now that independent expenditure means
the dispers ment of funds for an
expenditure made by a political
committee or person that promotes the
success or defeat of any candidate or
measure that is made without and then it
continues as it was already written in
the draft that came back from the Senate
and the reason for that is that she
wanted to make it clear that it would
promote the SE success or defeat of any
candidate because that's in the current
statute and she wanted to make it clear
that that was the
case so that's um um 30 and
three weren't that many changes to be
honest
um on page eight and I'll have her
confirm this when she gets here but um
it's not page eight I'm
sorry it's page eight on our previous
draft
nine um line
22 the L the language except for the
statement in paragraph Roman numeral I
below which shall be inclusive through
the Tuesday before the statement is due
that was added by um deputy secretary of
state um Aaron Hennessy to make sure
that the last two days of the election
cycle were included in the last report
which is um I which is
the oh okay I didn't but good all right
so it's not an addition and then
everything else is the
6644 changed a bit and this is what I
wanted Senator Susi to get back to me on
because I haven't had her confirm this
yet
um it has to do with the removal of
political advocacy committees in the
oh okay oh it's still in okay well page
seven at the bottom it's line 32 and
then it continues over onto page
eight no it's I'm sorry they're both on
line 32 political advocacy organization
on line 32 um we asked whether it should
come out because in line 31 it says any
other political committee and a
political advocacy organization is a
political committee so it wasn't making
sense to us to have them both in there
one at 30 and one it
unlimited so she was going to check and
get back to me on
out and it looks to me when you turn
over on page eight that there's
something missing
35 and then
36 there should
there okay so this isn't necessarily the
finished product this is not the
finished
product do you want to mark it up this
is a
lot I guess my suggestion would be to
break and not try to dig into this right
now break until a mutually agreeable
time later after both sides have had a
chance to review this it's up to you
Senator I think
that we need a final
version unfortunate that sus has a
conflicting
committee well I think it will only take
us 10 or 15 minutes to go through
it I know getting back together is the
hardest part but yeah well yeah not
everyone needs to show up if we have an
agreement I'm around all day so what's
up I'm around all day
so there's no escaping Senator
abis all right so do you want to do that
yeah if you recess it for a half an hour
or something and then we're late then
nobody's going to kill us if we're late
yeah I can't recess then we have to do
it tomorrow okay whatever whatever the
house rules allow you to do to get a a
postponement for it's easy I simply
announce a break okay and then you and I
figure out when we want to come back and
when we figure that out we just do it
okay all right so that's what's
happening there'll be no gavel cuz this
is not closed we're simply on a
break all right let's move on to the
next
one
we'll open the committee conference on
House
Bill
once Mr chairman I would just say that I
think the the Senate position is
reasonable the chain simply said that um
essentially uh change it from two free
request to one and allow for other
Electronic media provided by the clerk
so it doesn't need to be sent via email
discussion house conf is okay with the
changes Senate's
fine
yes okay I guess we're good with your
and oddly now we have to wait 10
fast was that
AIS
yes
right oh yeah that's the first thing
thank you
not C I do have copy of
that which is that that's what I was
going by but there were some some
changes that Senator Su and IED about G
be after the last bill because he's
around 15 minutes with in my hand and I
you that'll be back it'll be this
afternoon because they're going to need
you
e
is there
discussion representative
qua
well thank you Mr chairman uh my
understanding of the differences between
the House and Senate positions is that
the house position called for having the
uh checklist updated every four years
starting in 2027 with a 4-year look back
period meaning that someone hadn't voted
in four years they would be removed from
the checklist the Senate position as I
understand it was again a uh having the
checklist updated every four years with
a six-year lookback period starting in
2025 and personally I think that the
Senate position is acceptable thank you
discussion Mr chair I don't know when
the appropriate time to tell you this is
but I will not be able to sign this
report okay
so and Senator gray I think you
explained the idea was that if um
somebody missed two presidential
elections then they got flagged on
this we moved the date from 27 back to
25 so it would happen right after the
presidential election and then we did
look back two years because most of the
voters that are affected by this are
voters who
who through their own choice usually
vote just in the presidential elections
and so this uh hopefully will cut down
on the number of people who come in and
have to
re-register uh but if we do implement
the provisions in
1370 if they are or were registered they
would not have to prove citizenship Etc
they would only be required to prove uh
uh identity and uh Gan for the their
existing
else then I think the report will be to
you
e
all right we'll open the committee of
1370 is there discussion uh
yes uh I sent around a uh an amendment
last night 2226
and if anybody doesn't have a hard copy
of it I have some right here just tell
uh this will require a change that on
line six on page
one um near the end of the thing it says
the Mover and that was supposed to be
either voter or applicant and applicant
is the word that I want uh because the
two lines above that we talk about by
the applicant uh because they are until
they get uh certified and registered
they're an applicant so uh that's one
change uh the other thing that we did
talk about and that's on page two uh on
the back is the
appropriation and we talked about that
when we talked about the portal Bill
463 is that if we're going to make this
work that does need to be in appr
appropriation the appropriation was in
463 463 looks like it is uh going to be
uh not concurred on uh so that we would
need uh the $100,000 that I put in here
uh to do uh the things that stand up
that group on Election Day uh but this
actually has that group available
through uh noon time on Friday uh for
making adjustments
um and if we're going to also do the uh
tablets that would have the database on
there for the whole state uh so the per
person who comes in and says I'm in
Manchester w i was registered in
Manchester 1 and now I'm in Manchester 7
or wherever uh they would be able to
look that person up and they would not
need to prove uh anything but uh their
identity and
doicy uh and that because of the actions
we took on 63 that 100,000 may actually
need to go up some uh to to accomplish
all that within the funds that we have
uh but this would also decrease the
amount of time that the investigator in
the AG's office uh has to spend uh the
data that I got from uh 15 uh 16117
election time period uh from the
Secretary of State said that they spent
uh
871 hours and that's the last data that
I have uh for that uh on those
investigations which is almost a half a
man year um so uh I think that uh with
the addition of this amendment uh we are
on track we will uh be able to withstand
any challenge either from the court or
someone who thinks that
uh we're going to lose Motor Voter
because on Election Day anybody that
comes in if they thought they had proper
documentation uh this the way it's
written right now would give them relief
either through the court or be able to
provide that documentation themselves uh
by noon time on Friday or they would be
able to uh uh the group if they could
verify it after the fact they would be
able to but remember it is still the
voter's responsibility or the
applicant's responsibility whatever you
want to call them at that time uh to
provide the
documentation uh that they have
established a domicile that they are a
citizen and they have attained the age
and to prove any of those you first have
to prove identity uh because your
documents like your birth certificate uh
you know doesn't prove identity and so
you need to to know that so those are my
comments I don't know if any the
Senators have additional
comments I have a question the the
effective date on the
bill
yep is so a lot of these changes if it
were uh on upon Passage would they
impact the next election
correct and my conversations with
secretary of state is that he can be
and see he didn't even shake his head no
that you have to go up
is what about changing the effective day
election question for the senator
actually
um the having these provisions go into
effect before the primary you know gives
you an election before the general
election to try out everything that's
going on I would expect that the
provision in here for data verification
ballot would be higher in the primary
because people are getting used to the
process um and if if I don't make it
effective then I don't get the benefits
of that either for the voter or for the
State uh and and that's why although it
be hurried uh the Secretary of State if
he's got the time to uh to do it then
I'm that's when it should happen Mr
secretary you're
up not at
what so about getting this implemented
for the upcoming
election my question is I know that a
lot of legal challenges to changes in
election
law uh especially for injunctive Relief
are successful when it's close which is
not actually properly legally defined as
far as I can tell to an upcoming
election is there risk of us making
these changes for the upcoming
election there is no question that that
either this bill or
1569 changes the process enough that we
are going to have to do extensive
training uh with local election
officials and the general public to help
them understand uh what the law change
is we're certainly willing to make every
effort uh to do that but there are three
months between now and the state primary
election uh and five months before the
so you think it's okay to implement this
immediately I think if that's the choice
of this legislature we would do
everything in our power to make it
happen Okay further discussion Senator
gray there are good parts in this bill I
I do not want you to push the date out
uh but parts of this like standing up
that group uh and having tablets
available at the various polling places
so that people people don't have to
prove citizenship is a benefit to the
voter it's a benefit to the people who
are doing it it should make the process
go quicker and smoother so there are
benefits in this uh but again you know I
believe that we can withstand the court
challenge uh at some point you know I
imagine that there will be a challenge
but everyone who walks into that
poll that provides information
disproven by a research of the
information is actually going to get to
vote on that day some of them may have
to provide additional information but
again you know we will try to help them
do that but it's still the voter's
documentation further discussion
represent
L um are you are you aware that the
clerks and uh Association is against
this bill for exactly the same reason
that you
indicated and um have you talked with
the clerks about getting this
implemented and what's going to happen
in a
very um uh shall we say watched election
um question is for
me sorry it was for Senator gray okay uh
I have talked to various people in the
clerk's Association I've talked to them
over the years and one thing I can tell
you is uh pretty much
consisteny if a clerk um is required to
do more than the clerk's Association uh
normally comes in and opposes whatever
bill it is okay right now this bill is
uh aimed at the voter it is aimed at
election Integrity it is trying to uh
satisfy both the people on the far right
and the far left uh that we are doing
everything that we can do uh to help the
voter uh except just taking their word
in the
201 uh 1617 data which was compr uh
compiled by the AG's office there were
affidavits that the inspectors in the
AG's office could not verify could not
find the
people yes we have not had a lot of
people who have been
prosecuted but 230 that I can't find now
there is a disclaimer in the report and
I agree with it that I do not believe
that all 230 of those people voted
improperly
I don't think the number would be
anywhere near
230 but just because it happens
infrequently you still lock your door at
night you still lock your car when you
park it here in the parking lot you
still do all those things to in ensure
the safety and integrity of your
curtilage and your
property this is just another measure
this is instead of having a person come
in not have the documentation fill out
an affidavit and then have them in
investigated we're taking out the
documentation we're taking out that
affidavit and we're going to do the
inspection or the investigation on
election day but if for some reason we
can't this amendment gives them an out
they can provide the documentation
within the we'll say noon time on
Tuesday to noon time on Friday is three
days okay and we will also try to assist
them in getting that information through
this group and that this amendment does
that further
discussion represent Lane um this is for
Secretary of State um scandin have have
you talked with anybody um at the
federal
doj um to assure us that we're not going
to lose um our status under
NV National the national voter
registration I have not spoken with
anybody from the federal
doj uh New Hampshire has an exemption
from the national voter registration act
because we have election day
registration um I don't see anything in
this bill that you know where the
statute eliminates election day
registration
uh voters as long as they bring in the
documentation that is required uh will
have the opportunity to register and
vote going beyond that you know if
voters have trouble with that process on
the day of the election you know does
that constitute a violation I I don't
know the answer to that that's a legal
I have more questions I'm assuming
you're just going to go through all this
would that would make it simpler if I
just asked the Secretary of State to
answer those
questions um would you be willing those
were very thoughtful questions by the
way thank
you um do you think that you could run
through them and answer them for us
because they're concerns that I know
that you and I have spoken about and
that others have spoken about
out
certainly so I the first one I just
answered uh the second question have you
talked with anyone I answered that one
too so
um what percentage of granite Staters
were born outside of New Hampshire uh I
don't have that number but I would
safely say that there is a high number
of uh
citizens and voters in New Hampshire who
were not born in the state what I do
know is that there are about 45,000
voters that were born in different
countries and of those uh uh about
7,000 used a qualified voter affidavit
to prove their citizenship
qualifications can I inter I guess I
don't understand the the purpose why do
we want to know how many Gran Staters
were born outside of New Hampshire well
because it is often very difficult in my
case it was very difficult to obtain a
birth certificate because uh the
hospital that I was born in was burned
down as were their records so it was
very difficult for me I also when I got
married I did not uh take my husband's
name but then took it later so when I
went to register I had to get a copy of
my divorce certificate so these are
steps that I don't think people expect
to be taking and I guess I want to bring
that home that this is a whole new
regime for people who want to register
to vote where you from I was born in the
great state of West Virginia oh maybe
that's it I was born in New York in
1964 seeing the horrible mistake they
made they tore down the hospital in
1965 and a couple of years ago I had to
get my birth certificate I never got out
of my jammies or left my house I did it
online I couldn't just apply for one and
they sent it to me um I don't you were
lucky maybe that was a product of West
Virginia senator gray um some of the
data that uh representative Lan is is
speaking to is supported by by other
things that are going on uh if
uh there's a a a what they call a save
database and that's uh
systematic alien verification for
entitlements program that has a lot of
information about people's citizenship
uh there is uh the data that is behind
the scenes for your uh real ID uh the ID
itself doesn't have the data but it is
in a database where a person for the D
from the DMV has actually looked at your
birth certificate that you provided for
that there is uh information on
TransUnion uh certainly in my
conversations with the AG's office uh
one of the things we did is uh we had
him looked me up uh and he could tell me
uh within a year period of when I got my
Social Security and when I got my social
security number uh and there's a lot of
other information in TransUnion U that
is the kind of database between Equifax
and Transunion is where when you call up
and they say well we're going to ask you
some questions uh which of these three
places did you live in uh which of this
that or the other thing and Transunion
has that and remember that the criteria
is more likely than not okay so I I say
that a young person comes in uh and
they're uh driving a vehicle okay that
vehicle may be registered in their
mother and father's name but since
they're driving it and they are 18 years
old or 19 years old and they said they
live at the same residence well that in
itself might not be sufficient but if
there's one or two other pieces you
quickly get to the level of it's more
likely than not that their domicile is
wherever um and again you know we're
doing what we can but again it's the
voter's responsibility to provide the
documentation it is not the state's
responsibility thank
you could you continue general question
is this bill changing the voter
requirements or just the
documentation repent Lane
cons could U the Secretary of State
please continue to answer the questions
raised what was asking if the Secretary
of State could continue to answer the
questions that were raised in Senator
susi's in my letter to
him have ADD it and a key piece is how
the bill affects the
question uh so the next question is how
will these measures impact married women
whose names may not match their birth
certificates will they bring their
marriage certificates and what if they
were married outside of New
Hampshire I don't know the answer to
that question other than to say that
that
is an
identity uh issue and New Hampshire
currently has voter ID law uh where a
voter has to show their uh
uh their photo identity to obtain a
ballot and issues related to that would
be addressed in that process and right
now we know that it is just a fraction
of one % of Voters who do not have uh
the appropriate
identification and currently have to
fill out a challenge voter affidavit and
taken the next question is what
Provisions are there for US citizens
born
abroad uh including those born to
military
families again if a uh um
if it's a United States citizen they
should have documentation whether it's a
passport or whatnot that they can bring
in uh military uh Personnel registering
to vote have to comply with Federal
requirements in that process and they
simply have to fill out a federal
postcard application to become
registered to vote and I don't believe
that changes uh with this proposed
legislation how many voters will these
bills
affect um again I don't have a specific
number that I can give you what I can
tell you is uh historical numbers uh New
Hampshire went through a verification of
the checklist some people call it a
purge where there were about
175,000 names removed from the
checklist and what happens in the
election or two after that occurs are
those individuals will re-register to
get back onto the checklist my
understanding of the reading of this
bill is that once identity and domicile
are
established any voter who was priorly
registered in the system is would
automatically be accepted
so we know that in uh 2012 for example a
presidential election immediately
following a purge there were about
100,000 people registering to vote on
the day of the election uh in in that
election I would expect we're going to
have similar
numbers uh in this election this
presidential
election I would believe the large
percentage of those voters are
already in inactive in the system
uh but they would be quickly verified uh
by searching their identity in the
system so I think we're we would be
dealing with a number probably in the
low tens of thousands um you know in
terms of numbers of individuals tens of
thousands is that what you said I yes
25,000 what number of affected voter
do I consider acceptable um you know
obviously I firmly believe
that any voter who's qualified to vote
should be able to exercise that right uh
to be able to cast that vote uh I also
believe though that you know in New
Hampshire it is incredibly easy to
register to vote and to go to a polling
place and vote uh I think that it is a
legitimate concern of those people that
are concerned about who is
participating that they have uh backup
information that those individuals that
are participating are qualified so uh I
don't think that it is um voter
suppression or uh too much to ask voters
to be able
to you know give that confidence that
they're qualified to vote there are
limits I mean it can go to an extreme uh
in either direction but uh you know I
believe that asking for qualifications
unreasonable additionally what happens
if someone shows up to register without
a birth certificate or
passport uh as Senator gray mentioned
there is a provision in in this bill for
the Secretary of State to organize
basically a phone bag with other state
agencies that have access to databases
where this information uh would be
available and that it would be
uh up to my office and that call center
to try and confirm uh qualifications
within 20 minutes and if uh that
confirmation could not be made then
there was a process by which that voter
could cast either a a judicial review
ballot how long does it typically take
to obtain these documents and what are
the associated
costs
um you know I think we all know what the
process is for getting a driver's
license or a passport you know getting a
passport could cost uh you know a a
person depending on whether it's a pass
card or passport somewhere between I
don't know 80 and
$150 you know driver's license fees are
what they
are uh it's easy for a person to who's
born in New Hampshire to obtain a birth
certificate there for a reasonable cost
other states have different processes
for doing that are you
aware of how long it takes to get um
citizenship
not how how will our election officials
be prepared by September and what is my
response to their concerns
um my my response to their concerns is
that I agree that what has been being
asked is a significant new program and
it will require effort on the part of
every local election official to be
trained on this new process so that they
understand it I know from past
exercises you know on laws that have
passed uh we can do very extensive
training uh and there will be
individuals at at the local level that
uh will not do it properly uh as
innocent as you know those issues are uh
my office has already ramped up a very
significant training program that is
available to all uh local election
officials we do it in person we're doing
recording of training so that they're
available online we do webinars and so
we will we can make that effort to make
sure that the information is
available
again my office still has to develop
what these procedures are going to be
and then we have to train them uh within
a three-month window before the state
primary uh and then the big event in
November at the general
election regarding the proposed election
hotline how will it operate what will it
cost how many staff will it require
what is the expected duration of the
average call uh I don't know the answer
moment do you anticipate implementation
of this legislation could result in long
lines and delays and do all New
Hampshire polling places have adequate
cell phone service to support this
hotline um if this is not done properly
it could result in uh delays uh and
possibly voters leaving the polling
place
um the the Bill calls for extending the
call center for
verification Beyond just election day so
that we can continue to work to make
sure that voters who could not be
confirmed within that initial 20 minutes
have a thorough review um and have an
counted finally have you had any
discussions with other agencies such as
doj safety or
hotline how many agencies do you expect
to participate and how many people will
be required to staff the
calls how long you anticipate a voter
will need to wait for their information
to be
verified I have had superficial
conversations with other agencies uh and
they are willing to participate in this
effort obviously the objective and the
goal would be to make sure that we are
overstaffed in doing this as opposed to
understaffed uh but those details still
have to be worked
out I believe that is the questions that
you
ask further
discussion Senator
Avis thank you Mr chairman I just want
to understand if I I want to make sure I
understand this corre correctly we
there's qualifications be eligible to
vote and this is just requiring people
to demonstrate that they're actually
eligible to vote so I guess when it
comes to the
citizenship section if we're going to
make that a
requirement why is it an issue to make
sure we're able to verify that when
they're registering the vote I mean
otherwise it's just there on paper with
without any really Rhyme or Reason how
enforced representative Lan I think I
can answer that question um Most states
do not require um uh proof of
citizenship they take an affidavit um
the reason being that there are some
federal and there are state law uh uh
repercussions uh if you lie on an
affidavit uh statewise it's um up to
$5,000 and probably uh you would never
become a citizen because then you would
be down for fraud and you would never be
able to become a US citizen and it's
unlikely that somebody is going to try
to cheat to vote um and give up their
opportunity to become a US citizen um so
Most states don't have it and um I think
the fact that we're going to basically
disenfranchise 7,000 people
because there's no proof that anybody
has cheated on the citizen affidavit and
we are disenfranchising 7,000 people by
this
bill Senator Greg um I take accep to the
7,000 voters uh characterization uh the
question that was answered where the
7,000 came in was how many could be
affected that affected could be people
who didn't bring in an ID people who
didn't bring in proof of domicile people
who didn't and we
addressed the concerns that were brought
to us by the
opposition in every one of the things
that that we could address okay the
having a tablet uh available at the
Poland place will cut down on the
citizenship uh problems uh that you've
cited
considerably new registrations we could
probably get the number of how many were
new registrants that weren't you know
but that's going to cost us time and
money okay I can tell you by the 25
years that I was a moderator that it was
very few people Hampshire that weren't
brand new voters new either moov moved
into the state or whatever okay I've
talked to the Secretary of State about
having a public service announcements
that what we're doing and how to should
be done when we implemented the
affidavit ballot uh that took place
within the last few weeks before the
election it
was rarely used and and I'll let the
secretary he probably knows the number
okay and part of this is modeled after
that same thing but we're going to try
to help you if we
can if you have a real ID and it's in
the Hampshire fine if you have a a a a
vehicle registered in the Hampshire okay
when I talked to the DMV people they
said they could tell me every reg every
vehicle that I've ever registered here
in New
Hampshire okay if somebody walks in and
they says okay yeah I had a uh a Chevy
Nova a 1969 model that I registered
brand new and you know that's pretty
good indication that you know I am who I
say I am right that maybe a social media
account okay if you got a social media
account that's been up for five or six
years and you've got some other
corroborating information you meet the
requirement of more likely than not in
my opinion that'll be up to the
Secretary of State and how he trains
people we are not trying to
disenfranchise
anyone we are trying to help the V
voters meet their requirement to provide
documentation of citizenship of age of
doile and then like I say many of those
documents don't prove who they're for so
you then have to prove identity in
addition to those for those other
documents to work Mr chairman could I
just make a quick clarification that I
think is important that that 7,000
number was the number of of Voters that
filled out the qualified voter to
establish their citizenship that were
born out of the country those
individuals are now on the
checklist and so the only uh they were
already on the checklist as long as they
prove their identity uh when they go to
vote then they're going to be allowed to
oh thank you all right so I think I've
allowed a lot of latitude but this is
clearly devolving into a debate on the
bill and not the differences between the
house and the
Senate so let's try to zero win on
that Senator gray your
proposed
amendment right you want to change $1 to
100,000 the amendment uh
um has the the 100,000 in there and
that's to fund the things that we didn't
Fund in
463 uh the amendment does need at least
one word change and that's on line six
where it uh did an autoc correct and put
in mover instead of voter but the actual
correct word in there should be
applicant because they are not a voter
until they are registered so they are
applying so the the cor will not require
voters to carry furniture into the
polling place agreed
amen so those that's to the amendment
that is the only change I have uh if the
committee believes that you
know probably if if I were to put in
that dollar figure at the end right now
I would probably go to 150,000 since we
gutted all the money out of
463 uh and I was depending upon on part
of that to fund this but certainly
whatever the
committee's uh intent is or or comes to
there I don't see the Secretary of State
shaking his head no
so it's will 100,000 get us there I had
say you want 100
[Laughter]
Grand
okay
so changes to
the amended by the Senate
version your Amendment will have to fix
mover and I looked at the language on
the funding paragraph you just have to
change the number right I think the rest
of the language is adequate the
amendment already has the 100 th000 in
it
okay the only change that I know of to
my Amendment uh is changing that word
mover
okay anything
else go
ahead thank you Mr chair I just had one
mechanical question on the amendment on
line six where you have this 20 minute
window I wondered when who starts the
clock uh the wording that I put in there
is not verified or disproven within 20
minutes by the individuals trained by
the secretary of state so as soon as
they contact them that's when the clock
signal I'm I'm willing to change the the
wording in there to help you out uh I'm
just curious do you have a
suggestion yes but it's probably not
appropriate at this time
okay this says if we can't reconcile
their issue within 20 minutes once
yeah making it longer would just prolong
the
process and it but if they don't get
resolve in 20 minutes they they get the
Go cast their Bell and that's
it you want to make it shorter I think
okay so I think we can draft a
report that has this make
sure we don't have to be movers to vote
and and 100,000 was already in here
right y does the chair want me to do the
drafting of the amendment or is the
chair going to do OSS is going to ask is
this an amendment or a report let's not
I can do it if you need assist
additional assistance from me you know
I'd be more than happy to help
absolutely so this to the Senate amended
version fixing the word mover and and
we're
there
to and that changes to
voter I would I would say applicant
applicant and if you look two lines
above it says says presented by the
applicant so to be
consistent that mover should go to
it
and this 20 minute thing is that new uh
the 20 minute uh was
to in my discussions with the Secretary
of State you know we needed to have some
kind of a cut off I mean you know if a
person you know was working on it and
working on it and working on it and
that's
why because you have the affidavits
right now that there is a cuto off you
fill out the affidavit and then you go
on about your business and that's why we
put in you know uh pending judicial
review or data verification and
therefore put that time limit in there
but then those people at the site uh may
continue to work on that if they don't
receive another call that requires their
attention and may be able to resolve the
Day yep
okay all right anything else on this
we will close then the committee
1370 and what now
right now we're going to do 1596 because
it's
sched
pretty
e
all righty let's get open the committee
of conference on House Bill
FN uh I can s Senator G we we were fine
the only issue that we had was there was
a concern that an inadvertent regular
person didn't have a protection in the
language that that we have
representative
Brennan has brought us language that she
believes doesn't really change your bill
except adds an exemption for somebody
who sees a deep fake of I don't know
that evil representative Smith
being mean to puppies and goes oh my God
this is terrible and they repost it we
don't want them held liable because they
didn't do research or run analysis to
find out that I would never hurt a puppy
in fact I love dogs more than people
good
Reon I don't know if you can look at
this and decide now or if you want to
Senor I can just ask one question uh
lines four and five of the
amendment it appears in on under Roman
numeral 5A it just adds four content
provided by another
party what's the Reason by I guess
doesn't matter if it was provided by
another party or was the rational by
adding
that representative Brennan thank you um
the addition of that makes it consistent
with the other AI bill that has been
passed by both bodies that's hb1 1432
and so just to keep it consistent which
was really important to both the house
and the Senate that uh the language
between AI bills be consistent that is
the reason for this change thank you can
you give an example of an interactive
provider there may be someone who is
here here who would like to do that for
us otherwise I would say there are
experts who have advised us that this is
the most appropriate language my bad
um so for
example if I'm having a zoom meeting and
show a deep fake during the meeting Zoom
itself is exempt I believe is the intent
of
this thank you
okay
further we
set all right so the report will be the
amendment Mr chair do you need a formal
introduction of this amendment or
adoption of this amend mode or does it
just go with in the report
does um there is no Amendment there's a
report and this language will just being
incorporated into the report thank you
for that
clarification all
good all right thanks for playing let's
close House Bill 1596 and I believe that
concludes our business except for
right
e